How worried are the former Soviet states and
Ukraine’s neighbors?
Amid Russia’s ongoing invasion of Ukraine,
Conflict Zone heads to NATO’S front line:
the Baltic states.
They share borders with both Russia and Belarus,
and for years they’ve warned their allies
to stop ‘pressing the snooze button’ on
the security threat posed by Vladimir Putin.
My guest is Latvian Deputy Prime Minister
and Defense Minister, Artis Pabriks, he joins
me online from Riga.
“Our armed forces in Latvia, Estonia, Lithuania,
Poland, we are fully ready to defend our country
and we have a very high motivation.”
How far does he think Putin’s war will go?
Could it extend beyond Ukraine’s borders?
Might Putin use nuclear weapons?
And are Latvia’s NATO allies doing enough
to shore up the eastern flank.
Join me for all that and more on this special
edition of Conflict Zone.
Minister Artis Pabriks, welcome to Conflict
Zone.
Thank you.
Ukrainian President Zelensky has said this
week, "if we are no more, then God forbid,
Latvia, Lithuania, Estonia will be next."
Are you next?
Well, I believe that Ukrainians will win this
war, so there will be no next, hopefully.
But of course, we understand that if Ukraine
falls, then the pressure on all the border
countries with Russia will increase.
That's kind of clear from analysis, but we
are ready for this and we very much hope that
Ukrainians will hold.
I'm wondering how you think the Ukrainians
will win the war.
They've, they've called on NATO, for example,
to execute a no-fly zone, and it appears that
that has indeed been ruled out.
And when we look at your circumstances, for
example, when we just look at the map, you
share a border with both Russia and Belarus.
You and your allies in the Baltics are linked
to NATO's main territory by a land corridor
that is just 60 kilometers wide.
Back in 2016, NATO war games showed that Russia
would overrun the Baltics in under three days.
Surely you must be feeling vulnerable right
now?
Well, you know, yes.
On the one hand, we are small countries bordering
a huge aggressor state, which is now waging
war against Ukraine.
But on the other hand, you know, one thing
is war games and computer programs.
Another thing is real life, and you know that
many analysts, even in the West, have been
thinking that also Russian troops will overrun
Ukraine very smoothly and will take Kyiv.
But you see what is happening.
So from that perspective, I think life always
shows a difference.
But there is a huge difference between Ukraine
and, for instance, my country, Latvia, because
we are still members of European Union and
NATO.
Right.
And any kind of aggression towards us would
mean that there will be an all-over war.
And we've, we've heard statements iterated
by NATO.
For example, we heard [Secretary General Jens]
Stoltenberg saying that "every ally and every
inch of NATO territory will indeed be defended."
I'm just wondering how convinced you are right
now that your NATO allies will indeed be able
to ensure your security.
Even it comes if it comes to the cost of a
full-scale war with disastrous consequences
because the West has wasted no time praising
itself for unity in this crisis.
But are you convinced that will last in the
long haul?
Well, first of all, one of the reasons why
Russians invaded Ukraine was that in previous
conflicts — Georgian War 2008, Crimea annexation
in 2014 — the West was not sending strong
signals enough to Russia.
So Russians wrongly estimated that if they
invade Ukraine, the life will go on as usual.
And this is what Medvedev also told in this
pre-staged Security Council meeting about
10 days ago.
Now that appeared to be wrong because [Russian
President Vladimir] Putin united the West.
Now, as far as our conviction, a conviction
about Article 5, look, we are going here double
track.
First of all, our armed forces in Latvia,
Estonia, Lithuania, Poland, we are fully ready
to defend our country and we have a very high
motivation.
Secondly, on 24th of February, when I was
woken up shortly before four o'clock in the
morning when Russian aggression started, four
hours later, already American Airborne Battalion
landed in Latvia.
That's a proof [that] Article 5 holds and
as we talk now, we have also American commander
here in Latvia, which tells me the same.
We are one.
But Article 5 aside, let me ask you, Russia
has demanded, for example, prior to this invasion,
they demanded a legally-binding agreement
to exclude Ukraine and Georgia from NATO membership
and restrict NATO exercises and deployment
of various weapons in states bordering Russia,
states such as your own, states, such as Latvia.
Before the invasion of Ukraine, some of your
allies in NATO, including French President
[Emmanuel] Macron, hinted at the need to acknowledge
Russia's security concerns.
So there's unity now.
But could members make compromises if they're
pushed?
Well, they were mistaken then, because it's
very clear that there can't be made compromises
on our liberty, our freedom.
And if somebody wants to make concessions
or compromises, they should only speak about
themselves.
Now anyway, this stuff is over.
And of course, the Russian ultimatum, let's
say, proposed to NATO in those days, was clearly
only was one idea: that they understood that
NATO countries like mine, we simply cannot
accept such ultimatum because that would simply
mean to open borders to Russians.
It would be just the same if we would ask
Russians to withdraw all the troops behind
the Ural Mountains.
It's simply impossible.
Mr. Minister, I also want to ask you about
the threat of nuclear, because there's been
a lot of concern over nuclear force or of
a potential nuclear accident occurring.
In the past days, Ukrainian officials reported
a fire set off by a raging gun battle at Europe's
largest nuclear power plant in southeastern
Ukraine.
Putin, meantime, has put Russia's nuclear
arsenal as on alert as we know.
Your country's foreign minister, amid all
of this, called it a bluff to try and influence
both Ukraine and the West.
How can you be sure of that, that Putin's
threat, that the use of nuclear weapons is
just a bluff?
Well, first of all, Russia — and Putin — is
using strategic communication very nicely.
His major idea is to split us and to scare
us.
And the fact by itself that we speak about
this threat simply means that he reached the
ears.
Yes, of course, he will try to threaten us.
He will tell us that, ‘look, if you will
not give up this or if you will not give up
that, we might use nuclear power because we
are a nuclear power.’
But first of all, that would be disastrous
consequences for himself.
And secondly, we are also, as far as intelligence,
observing what they are doing.
We will know if he does something.
At this moment, we don't have such type of
intelligence.
But, but I'm asking you to just to just look
at the actions that he has taken now in the
past weeks, and the words that are coming
out of his mouth.
I mean, he has threatened, and I'm quoting
here "consequences you have never faced in
your history" as he put Russia's nuclear weapons
on high alert.
There's literally nobody between him and the
nuclear button.
Do you really think he's behaving like a rational
actor right now?
He's not behaving responsibly as a leader
or a president or whoever he is, of [how]
a country with nuclear power should act.
But, you know, still the situation even in
Russia is not that, for instance, Putin is
waking up in the morning and he has a bad
mood, so he's just reaching the red button
and pressing it.
This doesn't happen even in Russia.
So we very much believe that there is still
a chance to talk and let's say, to avoid such
type of activities.
And we don't have, in fact, other alternatives
because we cannot simply to give up to a bully
who is telling "look, if you will not do this
or that, I will press the button, I will press
the button."
This is not how we can act.
So as only chance is simply to keep cool heads,
to support Ukrainians in their freedom fight
against invasion, and exile, exaggerate, with
sanctions, because these economic sanctions
acts and will make Russia and the Russian
people reconsider.
One of those initiatives that you have been
trying to pursue in order to support Ukraine,
your president has called on the EU to stop
being "a political midget," that's the words
that he used, and allow Ukraine candidate
status to join the bloc.
Isn't it too little, too late for Ukraine
for that?
You know, Ukraine — European Union, is large
but also a slow organization.
But I would say that Ukrainians deserved and
paid by their blood already to get this accession
country status.
It will anyway take time.
But I believe that one day, when this war
will be over, we will all be ready to support
with something similar to Marshall Plan, to
recreate Ukraine.
And I believe that they will be … members
of EU.
Not today, not tomorrow, but let's say, some
three to five years.
And that should be made possible because they
deserve this, they paid by blood for membership.
So you don't think it will be just another
unfulfilled promise?
Because I mean, they had the promise that
they would have NATO membership.
They were promised that back in 2008, that
promise...
No, no, no.
There were no such promises and this was exaggeration
also from Russian side, because nobody seriously
were thinking that Ukraine could become a
NATO member within the nearest ten years.
So there was not even NATO plan for that,
because it was Putin's exaggeration.
But about EU now, because of this war, I really
strongly believe there will be a lot of supporters.
And Ukraine will be a member of the EU.
Minister, just briefly before we go: Secretary
of State Antony Blinken said on Wednesday
that the United States was keeping the door
open to diplomatic ways forward with Russia.
Do you see any prospect for a face-saving
off-ramp for Putin right now?
Well, not on the behalf of Ukrainians and
their sacrifices.
If he wants a face-saving, he has to figure
out how to do this.
If he withdraw his troops, if he stops the
war, yes, we might start to lift maybe some
sanctions.
But first of all, he has to do something,
because usually with Russians, it happens
that they speak one [thing] and they do something
totally different.
Such type of policies cannot succeed.
Who could broker a deal with Russia?
Excuse me?
Who could broker a deal with Russia right
now?
Well, I think we all, if we stand together,
Europeans and Americans, and actually I'm
still looking forward what’s the big Chinese
response.
Latvian Deputy Prime Minister and Defense
Minister Artis Pabriks, thank you so much
for joining us on Conflict Zone.
Thank you, madame, for inviting.